欢迎收看最佛心幽默的财经节目
理财达人秀
我是李兆华
好 节目一直提醒大家
升息的锅盖拿起来的话
我们即将迎来一个开开心心的光辉十月
以及第四季
今天盘面似乎就迫不及待了
越涨越多
中场上涨了八百九十几点
而且贵买今天足足上涨了三点六个百分点
哇 今天算是一个百花齐放
体感温度非常好的一天
昨天我们说下上一线涨一半
大家半信半疑
今天似乎连成交量都来到了一兆以上
好到底有没有什么事情值得留意呢
其实像今天台币是升值的
因为外资大买台股
也是将近900亿元
整个半导体上中下游
几乎都有涨停的代表作
难道跟黄仁勋的一句话说
明年的晶片销售要翻倍有关
还是有什么样我们没有看到的契机跟商机
现在进场还来得及吗
因为今天收收在47000点以上
好下个礼拜的布局格外重要
因为礼拜五是中秋节廉假开始
四个交易日要做哪些事
今天一起告诉您来欢迎来宾
第一位是盈利投资的中国中
中总
好中总要提醒大家
有一个很关键的事情是
台湾央行没有升息哦
日央升息美央升息欧央升息
我们没升息代表什么呢
代表我们的环境很宽松啊
企业要融资成本是低的
是根本大放水的一个环境
但钟大胆也要提醒大家
下个礼拜四个交易日
我们先不要急哦
我们先来看
第一他很在意MSCI的动态哦
过去历年都一定有代表做
这一次会拱谁
今天独家猜猜看哦
告诉你谁会脱颖而出
再来有一个廉价了
所以不妨布局一些
有高值利率的廉价消费股
等到下礼拜有一天
钟大胆说积极进场
等一下告诉您
第二位是我们的国家级基金操盘手
黄丰凯 凯哥
凯哥来也要讲
今天半导体好帅
上中下游
都有人大涨甚至唱历史新高
是因为任勋哥的一席话吗
是因为下个礼拜
有台积电的技术论坛吗
等一下把理由告诉您
但关心投信的动态
前阵子真的比较保守
都买了很多金融股
风向现在吹了
等一下邦尼独家见证
投信买了哪一些从金融转AI的
里面不少叫做CPO
CPO的延续力
等一下凯哥也来告诉您
好第三位是我们的筹码专家全镇小哥
好各位好来讲
这礼拜的鬼故事好多
那当然其中一个就是
铜箔机版三雄的故事
今天筹码有没有转好
或是到底整体PCB筹码的状况呢
哥帮您做扫描了
但是他有提到
看起來資金有從PCB
稍微轉到哪裡去
封測股
今天封測股的表現非常強勁
晶圓電還漲停板
好 到底主力有沒有布局封測
答案是有的
以及會告訴您
掃出來第四季能夠續強的
主投買好股票喔
好 首先有請鍾娜達安
早好
好 再次恭喜您出書
排行榜上居高不下
謝謝 謝謝
大家趕快搶喔
謝謝
但是我們的央行厲害了
蓮石棟
本來大家都覺得這次要升
結果沒有
你覺得這在醞釀一個大放水行情
今天幫我們看MSCI
這一次會拱出來的
以及廉價的消費股
是 我們先來看今天市場上
大多數的國家現在都是上漲
我覺得最主要還是在這兩天
各國的貨幣政策
也陸續都有已經
把底牌都揭曉出來了
我們先來看台灣
楊金龍的部分
這邊昨天提到過
維持2%不變 年10棟
CPI今年2.03
明年2%以下
所以他說目前我們不跟著美國
做一個升息動作
那今年的GDP會上去到11.48
坦白講他這個部分
已經也暗示了一些想法
我的猜測就是央行創造低利率的環境而且我認為說下次12月份升息的理由应该不高为什么因为这次他已经讲说明年CPI会有2%以下
所以这次不升息
那下次呢
那更没有理由要升息
所以换句话说
也就是说变相的一个资金宽松
那日央呢
也接下来今天也宣布了朝生一马
因为最主要是8月核心的通膨放缓到
1.7%比预期低
日元部分我們上禮拜已經提到過了
他沒有在做升值 表示什麼
就是這個粉杯要扁了
對這種升息的態度的想法
已經大概已經打了預防針
不過我要特別強調一下
這個已經來到157
這條線叫連線
連線代表就是一個中長期的趨勢
換句話說
這次已經反映這一塊的部分
換句話說下個禮拜應該
日幣的部分有可能會再做升值的部分
同樣上禮拜我們跟大家提到過
央行 我發現我跟央行真的一樣
我們說31塊半會來到32
32優要準備要升值
這幾天又升值下去
所以你只要把那個抓好之後
其實上外資也在做這樣的動作
那我們現在看
這禮拜的行情部分
我們怎麼看
坦白講我還是會認為是高出低進
像這禮拜我個人要做的話
我禮拜二禮拜三
罷盤大跌到四萬五千多點
那很好機會
那今天就開始要做
自當做一月先
為什麼
這個禮拜大家如果看
今天的盤好像是不錯
興高采烈
但這個禮拜的量是3.77兆
創下新低量
而且還加上0050盤後的生效
如果沒有這個量
那量還更低
這是6月份以來的新低量
那下禮拜應該還會更新低量
因為下禮拜不連下效應
當時我上禮拜提到過
這禮拜是一個關鍵週
什麼叫關鍵週
它會決定後面的後半個月
到底是要強還是弱
那最後面是上漲
說表示這個部分的流浪
下半個月會維持一個交付高檔值
也就是說已經不太會
一個弱勢格局跌到很低的位置去
那短線之間會看45,200
收盤在47,000以上的不多
那今天收盤盤有在47,000
我可以認為說下禮拜一
不用考慮太多
禮拜一就先高出
然後再低接
等到什麼低接
等到禮拜四大家去放假的時候
要賣的時候你再來接
8月31號的大量1.2兆
我上次提到過
4548年很重要
上次提到過
那這波這禮拜最低點
就是45398
換句話說
這個付費MFCI的這個
當然天的大量
確實是很重要的參考點
所以我覺得這個位置
45000應該是附近是
近期比較重要的參考位置點
不過我可惜就是
9000KD43
不上不下
也沒有拉到很低
也沒有很高
所以就很尷尬
不過因為我認為說
有個不確定性很高
是因為包括今天美國
還有一個四五日結算
下個禮拜有不少國家要放長假
你看今天的日本沒漲很多
相對台灣 日本 韓國
這幾個國家比
因為下禮拜日本要休秋分日
開始要休好幾天
還有一個川喜會
所以我個人會是
長假前最後一天買進
就是至少有那個賣壓的部分
你可以去做接
因為你今天去買
禮拜一 禮拜二就人
尤其是禮拜二就是中秋節
資金要抽回的最後一天
換句話說禮拜一你不賣
禮拜二一定會有賣
因為連長三天了
所以個人覺得這部分是
禮拜一不用考慮
有高檔先做賣掉
等什麼時候
等到大家賣的時候
你再來做地界的動作
長假消費大家擔心
反而我們要勇敢
另外一個因素是因為什麼
上規市場上的法人後半週
各位看一下
我一直講叫OTC
OTC這個是大家看這個
法人的所謂
它現在來到近期的新低
換句話說
你現在看上次是大買
但是OTC它卻是把它做一個
在節前或是在這段時間把它賣掉換句話說看起來是這部分還是有點擔心的部分所以我個人是認為說如果有這樣的情況的話那這個位置來到47000以上
我認為是說不用去做追
你今天買的不用去做追
但是第四季的行情不錯
所以下禮拜如果拉回來的時候
你再去做一個買進
短期的資金
日量不會過照
投資本說今天不會過照
沒有每天有0050的
所以今天0050的盤後生效扣掉
它只有8000多億
短線的一定做短衝
這個如果你做短線的
你可以再衝來衝去
中線的你就可以報過節
安心的過
因為中秋節
你就不管川普講什麼
跟習近平講什麼話
你都跟我們沒關係
還是你就報著這些股票
至少可以安心的過日子
對
那來看一下美國的走勢
道瓊這波最高
但是這波已經殺下來
到這個位置半年線
而且季線下彎
上升趨勢線法是什麼
這個走勢已經
原本強的已經變弱了
那原本弱的像台積電
ADR或費城半導體
是原本最弱的現在開始變強
轉強
已經告訴你一件事情
市場上已經開始慢慢
從南投股已經轉到科技股去了
換句話說這個風向已經
在醞釀說
第四季應該慢慢會
慢慢主導在這塊部分
所以我想這個告訴你
這個進級的趨勢
是有這樣的現象
好 那來看一下
Emerity在新增的成分組
上次新增的是最強是台宏
再來是順德
其實到順德最近還是很強
那看起來目前
因為我認為說
MCI每次都會代表做
我長期追蹤
誰
所以到目前我幫大家做追蹤
大概目前比較排名在前幾名
我看一下目前的走勢比較好
包括雍字科
雍字科
對 這是高價位的
那這個現行加創反彈的新高
這個你可以等拉回
因為它這個上升趨勢
其實看起來是很明顯的
當然給我待會凱哥
願意多補充
待會他來講
凱哥可能會投嗎
因為他這個部分看起來
半導體的一個測試介面的部分
看起來大概目前是
這裡面幾家當中
它是算是目前走得最強的部分
不過因為價格比較高
所以節潛如果有拉回
我認為是說可以考慮這個位置
另外一個叫中價位的
就京居
京居有上次講過
這個性價比算是比較
這幾家公司算是比較好
不過因為最近的
這個PCB的材料 雜音油
雜音油 藍品就會有看多的
也有看不好的
所以會互相削減
我個人覺得如果可以的話
如果有壓回也可以再做留意
因為它最近的籌碼是有點會比較
沒有像這個那麼好 那麼穩定
那機器人呢 這個低價位的盟利
我上次有提到過了
那這個部分它最近有拉回到
這個技術線附近有守住
我個人覺得如果這塊
機器人長期的方向是OK的話
我覺得這個部分倒是也是可以留意
我想分高家会跟中家会低家会
投资人就去做观察
那另外还有一个也不错啦
和声堂
但是因为最近的被动院线
不是那么起义性的强制
大致上原则上这四家公司
目前是看起来是
最有机会的
最有机会
但我会陆续观察啦
我会在节目当中
仔细做观察的部分
但是接下来的话
有廉价的效应
还是先建议大家
要把握这种廉价里面
消费的概念股
我会挑几家公司
一个就是内需
过几个四天
你會去哪邊
你一定是去內需消費
或還有第四季
犒賞自己
出國就長榮航空
當然現在飛機早就去買好
但是問題是接下來是11系12
要出國像小哥也要出國
類似這樣子
大家也都要出國
我也是要出國
你也是
你剛才討論我有聽到
是啊
那新光金跟台信新光金
跟中信金就是
這個銷金的信用卡的部分
坦白講他們目前的EPS的部分
看起來銀行股不錯
那這個殖利率我大概預估
它明年來講到目前應該
這些都有四五罰左右
算還不錯
所以我先講一家公司
先講就從中信
中信金
會講這家公司
是因為我個人覺得
前陣子的金融股漲得蠻多的它倒是漲得比較慢那我們想想看為什麼漲得慢是因為後來它公佈它的上半年的EPS大概將近2塊 然後連真將近有317%
前8月份的稅後 他們後來有自節的部分
大概2.7 那今年EPS有機會挑戰4塊3
所以我如果算一算的話
它EPS這樣算起來的話
它大概明年股力應該有3塊錢
那你看1塊1塊8 2塊3 2塊半
明年有機會3塊
其實它的股息值率大概是4.2左右
那股利延續年年成長
禁止大概35塊
因為大家可能會看銀行
都是看股息殖利率
但是不要忘記
它一個Bull Value非常重要
它的禁止裡面相對
我看也是算是在銀行裡面當中
是比較高的部分
所以從這個幾個角度
來看一下這家公司
其實股價很強勢
它很強勢
但是最重要的是
你不要買乖離太高的
你看它這邊一直打底打很久
那最近開始走比較強
為什麼
最近的外資跟投信開始買
尤其投信大概在9月初開始買
你看投信的成本
很明顯這樣切下去就知道
投信的成本就跟現在價錢差不多
你看看這邊套勞量不會很多
因為大概成交量多是成交在這附近
如果它目前是受限到
它的歷史最高價73.6元
但如果把它還原全值
還原息值
其實它已經創下歷史新高
而且MACD即將這個州的部分
即將有可能會創向上交叉
所以我個人認為說
如果未來第四季是消費的旺季
那這些消金為主的
我個人覺得倒是可以去留意一下
因為很少看到外資跟投信
最近開始買這些所謂
剛期漲的部分金融股
我想這個應該是可以留意的部分
那另外一個就是遠東百貨
它的大巨蛋遠東Garden City
8月22號開幕
是台北最大的
北部最大的百貨公司
坦白講它的頻數算大
董作為說明年挑戰北區的業績王
那也因為這個位置
也因為它開幕後來
我真的實際去考察
去逛了是不是
上禮拜我去看一下
有些點真的還沒
店面還沒完全擺下去
因為那個是大店
就是國際的那種
國際品牌有些還沒入去
但是後來陸續都進去了
重點也是你看
它過去的
我們看它營業了
開始從5月6月份開始這邊
逐漸增加
如果一般人都很清楚了
母親節那檔完之後
接下來就是檔季了
它的營餘率很重要的是
創新高
毛利率也創新高
百貨公司
毛利率 營餘率創新高
不容易
因為現在說的賣
坦白講都是
營業也都是會有限
但是只能在管銷費用控管
所以我們發現
其實它每年的獲利是蠻穩定的
今年看起來是
上半年的獲利好像比之前來的衰退多
所以主要是
因為中國大陸那邊
有做一個業外的處置的部分
那它股息殖利率坦白講
每年都有一塊左右的股利的部分
那股息 禁值大概22塊
大概目前股進比在1%左右
所以如果順起來的話
它的殖利率大概有4.5左右
好 那我們來看它股價走勢
最近都一直在整理
那小編問我說
中總你為什麼要把它放那麼長的時間
對 為什麼要放這麼長呢
因為發了那麼長就要你對照
就六七八月也是這樣子
那11月呢
會突然
因為為什麼
你11月10號公佈
一夜就是那個什麼
週年慶的忘記
那你看起來
遠東百貨已經在這禮拜
已經開始週年慶了
那未來是就還是一樣
你就是想
未來是消費忘記是這樣走
還是消費忘記是這樣走
你自己去抓
但我個人是覺得
禁止不貝留是22塊錢
看起來目前大概在位置
所以各位去參考
如果未來中年輕來的時候
應該是有機會往上來做一個反應
這邊提供大家做參考
就總總去考察
但是接下來中年輕也要貢獻
我還在去考察看看
才能讓他這樣對不對
要實際花錢
是
這邊非常謝謝總總
謝謝趙華